hey everyone
litecoin a cryptocurrency is not a
recent invention it first entered the
market to compete with bitcoin
but litecoin lagged behind the growth of
bitcoin and was overtaken by rival
cryptocurrencies as they joined the
market
but despite the existence of rival
cryptocurrencies bitcoin continues to be
the market leader
however litecoin has a chance of
succeeding in the market
so
considering this hype here is a new
video on litecoin by simply learn to
enlighten you more about its concepts so
let's get started but before moving
ahead please hit the like button and do
subscribe to our youtube channel to
never miss an update from simply learn
well let's have a look at what you are
going to learn in this video about
litecoin
so first i will take you through
the definition of what is litecoin
followed by how it works
then i will let you explore the
differences between litecoin and bitcoin
then i will help you understand what are
the pros and cons of litecoin
then i will explain to you how litecoin
is used
following that i will explain to you how
litecoin is traded
and then i will let you explore why
trade litecoin with cmc markets
and then i will take you through the
factors that affect litecoin
and in the end why should you buy
litecoin
so let's get started with the video
first let me make you understand what is
litecoin
now the native cryptocurrency of the
open source blockchain project litecoin
whose code is a copy of bitcoins is ltc
as the silver to bitcoin's gold litecoin
was created to be more scalable and to
process transactions
considered more quickly than bitcoin in
october 2011
charlie lee a software engineer who had
previously worked at google
and the cryptocurrency exchange coinbase
announced the creation of the blockchain
on the bitcoin talk forum
now that we know what is litecoin let me
take you through how it actually works
now using an open source cryptographic
technology digital coins are created and
transferred using litecoin it keeps a
decentralized public ledger for all
transactions using blockchain technology
now what is blockchain technology a
shared digital ledger called the
blockchain contains a record of every
litecoin transaction by miners recent
cryptocurrency transactions are compiled
into blocks
after that the blocks are
cryptographically protected before being
connected to the pre-existing blockchain
now litecoin and bitcoin among other
cryptocurrencies also use similar
blockchain technology
now this raises a question that what is
mining
now mining is the process of employing
miners or mining software to secure each
block to the current blockchain the
release of new litecoin units occur when
a block has been secured these units can
be reintroduced into the market by
miners
well this raises another question that
how exactly litecoin differs from
bitcoin now this comparison will be made
on a few parameters
first is
coin release date litecoin was launched
on 7 october 2011 whereas bitcoin was
released on 9th jan 2009
second is
maximum coin supply
there is a limited supply of coins in
circulation for both bitcoin and
litecoin litecoin has 84 million coins
accessible which is almost four times as
many as bitcoin's 21 million
third is average transaction speed
now despite requiring more advanced
equipment than bitcoin to mine which
takes almost 10 minutes blocks in
litecoin are actually generated in 2.5
minutes up to four times faster
additionally litecoin executes financial
transactions much more quickly and can
handle more of them in the same amount
of time
fourth is
halving having interval for block
rewards their range is based on
basically market supply only
and the last one is mining algorithm a
cryptocurrencies blockchain can grow by
adding new blocks when miners
successfully solve hash functions
now litecoin and bitcoin employ
different mining algorithms script is
the hash function used by litecoin and
bitcoin utilizes she-256
now let me explain to you the pros and
cons of litecoin
now the popularity of litecoin started
to soar in 2017. five years later it is
still in demand and sells for over
70 dollars it has fed better than many
of its rivals during the recent
cryptocurrency sell-off but investments
always carry a risk
it's impressive how relative stability
has held up for litecoin throughout time
though it exhibits steadiness but lacks
the impressive growth that attracts
investors although the coins are
reasonably priced they are nonetheless
more expensive than most of their rivals
also litecoin's market capitalization is
smaller than other cryptocurrency and it
has lost market share as well also
litecoin is less speculative than many
of the younger coins even if all
cryptocurrency investments are
speculative
the expansion of litecoin may be
constrained by the fact that it is less
scalable than competitor blockchain like
stellar lumens so now that we have
covered the basics of litecoin let me
take you through how litecoin is exactly
used
now due to its strong liquidity litecoin
is a cryptocurrency with simpler trading
actually owners of litecoin will
discover the businesses like newegg
sling tv and even charities like the
american red cross are glad to take
their digital money to make a payment
with ltc you can alternatively utilize a
digital currency app like bitpay or
crypto pay
now you can use the binance app to send
money using ltc if you wish to use it
for peer-to-peer payments now let's see
how litecoin is exactly traded
now the price of one litecoin is
typically indicated against the us
dollar when purchasing it on an exchange
in other words you are selling usd to
purchase ltc if the price of litecoin
increases you can sell it for a profit
because it is now worth more in usd than
when you first purchase it now if you
opt to sell at a lower price and incur a
loss this is what will happen also you
can trade litecoin with cmc markets
using a spread bet or contract per
difference or save the account this
enables you to make price predictions
without actually owning the
cryptocurrency your possession of
litecoin is not transferred instead you
are taking a stake whose value will
fluctuate with changes in the price of
litecoin related to the us dollar
now that you know how litecoin is traded
let me explain to you why litecoin
should be traded with cmc markets so the
first reason is open a long or short
position
now you can trade on increasing and
falling prices with speed
betting at cfds to sell litecoin which
is not available on cryptocurrency
exchanges and you do not need to hold
any second is
efficient use of capital now when you
trade using leverage you merely put up a
small portion of the total trade value
to begin a position with well-known
cryptocurrency exchanges you must
deposit the entire contract's value
remember that both gains and losses will
be amplified and your risk losing for
more money than you initially invested
third is no exchange account or wallet
there is no requirement to open an
exchange account or wallet to store the
purchase litecoin in contrast to trading
the underlying cryptocurrency this
eliminates the need to wait for exchange
approval
worry about keeping your wallet secure
and pay fees if you decide to withdraw
money later
fourth is trade with an established
provider cmc markets is a licensed
provider with 29 years in the business
we provide assistance to all of our
customers anytime the markets are open
and fifth is trade responsibility for
most people cryptocurrencies are still
rather new and can be
very unstable they want our clients to
fully access comprehensive instructions
resources to support their trade now
let's have a look at the factors that
actually affect the ltc coin
now similar to bitcoin litecoins would
liability is likely influenced by the
following factors
first is regulation
governments in central banks presented
do not control cryptocurrencies there
are concerns about how this might evolve
over the coming years and it effect on
value
second is supply
there are only so many litecoins that
can be mined
which is 84 million the rate at which
coins are introduced to the market can
also effectively availability
third is press
public opinion security durability and
the pricing of competing
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin can all
impact litecoin prices
and fourth is adoption
neither consumers nor businesses have
yet embraced litecoin as a form of
payment however some believe that
blockchain technology has promise and
may one day be more widely used now the
biggest question of concern is
should you buy litecoin
according to blasky or big ira litecoin
might be a good addition to the
portfolio of an experienced
cryptocurrency investor who values its
stability and adaptability particularly
for those who want a combination store
or value asset with the side bonus of
convenient transactions
so according to some experts litecoin
might be a suitable investment for a
beginner looking to learn the ins and
outs of cryptocurrency trading media
makes the following conclusion about
whether ltc is a good option for your
wallet there are other blockchain
competitors that individuals may pick
from but litecoin still remains a
relevant choice so this was all about
litecoin i hope you find this video
interesting and informative if you have
any questions feel free to ask away in
the comment section our team will reach
out to you as soon as possible thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here